hey guys Ryan uh right is here kansui
thank you
hi price price is right we're back again
this video has been released by Joe Blow
calm Bryan Reynolds addresses the
Deadpool pg-13 rating for the longest
time he's been saying he's fighting for
an R rating if anyone knows Deadpool he
cannot be pg-13
there's just no [ __ ] way because he
is known for killing people and also
having such a what do they call the Merc
no mouth about not with American Merc
with a mouth sorry
mm I'm hoping that this video reveals
some good information for us yes me too
Logan it was the same it was like 15
Deadpool you out next year are you doing
Ryan pretty good Mario thanks for having
me
well thanks for taking the time and so I
would feel first of all to be back to
Dan Coover your hometown it's like a
homecoming huh yeah it is actually I
said I'm pretty lucky we got to shoot
here wasn't it wasn't any am i doing but
it's nice to be around my brothers were
around the huge Deadpool fans it's nice
a little coming for sure
cool it well let's talk about Deadpool
I'm vaguely familiar because of course
he was in wool oh yeah Wolverine he
wasn't Wolverine but that's not the
character work would not speak so
doesn't what did I know but that could
be Thea the most distinct feature he has
this is a guy that's morally flexible
and not and he doesn't care people we
were hated and I heard the the movie
studio just announced that they're in
for a pg-13 rating yeah we're working it
I mean yeah we're gonna keep the spirit
of comic book alive but I think it's
smart man that you guys keep it
family-friendly yeah I don't know if I'd
go you know so so far say it's you know
family-friendly Wow
there may be a billion reasons
yes yes fantastic way to make the
announcement fantastic way to make oh it
is him in the cost yeah okay cuz I was
wondering I was watching the interview
I'm like this feels scripted like it
really did it seems especially with
Mario Lopez like it seems so awkward and
I felt like Ryan Reynolds was feeling
like it seemed normal for Ryan Reynolds
no he still was kind of like in a weird
he was weirdly straight up and I don't
know if that makes any sense he was just
really straight up and down and yeah I
love how they I just love how they
promoted it with having a Deadpool
suddenly appear Brady the fourth of logs
is like [ __ ] with the whole imagery
of it all I could so Deadpool like and
to have him do that in his knock out
Mario Lopez was so funny at first when
it first came across I was like wait
that's him and then he comes back and he
yeah that was a great April Fool's Day
prank I love the fact that it's rated R
I love it that it just gives you so much
more faith because there was the test
footage that was released which I
thought was so awesome I didn't see it
Oh watch it really good it's so good the
test footage was like this is gonna be
something epic if they get this up I
think Ryan Reynolds makes it much better
Deadpool than he did at Green Lantern oh
yeah sure I mean they're two two totally
different characters Brandi you know can
you really compare Deadpool with Green
Lantern Green Lantern is you know the
average American hero is as opposed to
devil is like an antihero I guess so
yeah yeah
Greenlanders kind of an antihero in his
own right like he didn't want to be I
here let's not get technical about okay
let's not get technical about anyway
guys if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects brandy
has a channel to does a lot of fun movie
reviews on there you should check that
[ __ ] out and she has independent trailer
reactions to independent movie trailer
reactions yep it's not about like yeah
I'm free you could do reactions she
sometimes it is sometimes you can follow
us on Facebook Instagram and Twitter
cuz we like followers cuz followers need
us that's why you guys need us not the
other way around
don't ever forget that Christopher
Constantine oh yes right yeah hey guys I
was waiting for you get an awesome
shoutout yeah and at the same time
wanted to ask if you guys have any ideas
about this leaked trailer from comic-con
I believe it is anyway anyway now I'll
take a look at it later but yeah I would
really appreciate your video reaction if
you have not seen this thank you guys in
advance and keep up the awesome work if
my Greek surname is too hard to
pronounce and just give me a shout out
using my youtube name c gb 3 to 7 wow
what the what the hell is wrong with you
oh the video is no longer available man
sorry oh yeah me too it's like I don't
have the time to just watch a video I'm
a busy guy yeah on average night I never
watch videos ever
I don't watch videos unless I'm reacting
to the video
I haven't been to an actual movie
theater in years he's lying
cuz I'm doing movie your reactions now
you watch me react to a movie no matter
how long that film is check out my
Titanic reaction don't do it I've
already seen it several times so it's
not much of an interesting reaction
it was boring video let's be like the
whole time
Jack no I'm crying it I cried a lot
well now not now I made DiCaprio's too
well-known and I'd be so distracted by
the fact how young you yeah that's true
he does look really young in that he
does look young and I was got like a
Stewie head